TURNED ON THE FAUCET.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DEALING
WITH.
>> STAND BY.
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
THIS IS ABOUT THE JANUARY 6TH
INVESTIGATION.
THE COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING THE
CAPITAL ATTACK ISSUED SUBPOENAS
TO FIVE SITTING MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
THEY'RE ALL REPUBLICANS.
LET'S BRING UP THEIR NAMES AND
PICTURES.
KEVIN McCARTHY, CONGRESSMAN
SCOTT PERRY OF PENNSYLVANIA.
CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGS OF
ARIZONA.
CONGRESSMAN MOE BROOKS OF
ARIZONA AND JIM JORDAN OF OHIO.
THERE YOU SEE THEIR FACES.
RYAN NOBLES IS FOLLOWING THE
BREAKING DETAILS.
RYAN, WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
THIS?
WHY THESE FIVE CONGRESSMEN?
>> Reporter: THIS IS A GROUP OF
CONGRESSMAN THE COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN INTERESTED FROM ALMOST THE
VERY BEGINNING OF THEIR
INVESTIGATION AS WE REPORTED
OVER THE SUMMER, WHEN THEY
INITIALLY BEGAN LOOKING FOR
INFORMATION RELATED TO WHAT
HAPPENED HERE ON JANUARY 6TH,
THEY ASKED THE COURTS TO
PRESERVE OR ASKED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES TO
PRESERVE THE RECORDS OF A NUMBER
OF HOUSE MEMBERS AND THIS GROUP
WERE IN THAT DISCUSSION.
IN ADDITION THEY SENT LETTERS TO
SIX REPUBLICAN MEMBERS, AND THIS
FIVE WERE ALL IN THAT GROUP,
ASKING THEM TO VOLUNTARILY
COOPERATE WITH THE COMMITTEE'S
INVESTIGATION.
ALL SIX OF THEM THAT INCLUDED
THIS FIVE THAT HAVE BEEN ISSUED
SUBPOENAS TURNED DOWN THAT
REQUEST.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS WRESTLED WITH FOR
MANY MONTHS.
THEY KNEW THAT THESE REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS WERE NOT GOING TO BE
WILLING TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
THEY WERE HOPEFUL THEY MIGHT BE,
BUT THEY WERE VERY CONCERNED AND
THEY REMAIN CONCERNED THAT THESE
SUBPOENAS MAY NOT BE
ENFORCEABLE.
THERE IS NOT A LOT OF PRECEDENT
TO THE IDEA OF SITTING MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS BEING SUBPOENAED FOR
AN INVESTIGATION THAT'S BEING
CONDUCTED BY FELLOW MEMBERS OF
THE SAME BODY.
SO WE'VE ALREADY SEEN THE
COMMITTEE HAVE SOME DIFFICULTY
IN FORCING SUBPOENAS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION ABOUT ACTUALLY
SITTING MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
AND, OF COURSE, THE BIGGEST NAME
IN THIS GROUP IS THE CURRENT
MINORITY LEADER OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
KEVIN McCARTHY FROM CALIFORNIA
WHO IS HOPING AND VYING TO BE
THE NEXT SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
SHOULD THE REPUBLICANS TAKE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE IN THE FALL
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
McCARTHY HAS BEEN A TARGET OF
THIS INVESTIGATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
YOU'LL REMEMBER THAT HE STOOD IN
THE WAY OF ATTEMPTS TO CREATE AN
INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
COMMISSION THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED OUTSIDE THE CONGRESS.
HE ALSO STOOD IN THE WAY OF THE
ATTEMPTS TO CREATE THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE EVEN POLLING CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OFF OF
THE INITIAL FORMATION OF THE
COMMITTEE AFTER THE HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI HAD BLOCKED
SOME OF THE NAMES THAT HE HAD
ADDED TO IT.
SO THIS IS GOING TO CREATE A LOT
OF TENSION.
POTENTIALLY DRAMA BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S ALREADY SOMEWHAT
OF A TOXIC TRIERMT HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
THIS IS ONLY GOING TO ADD TO
THAT.
AND THEN THE BIG QUESTION IS HOW
DOES THIS IMPACT THEIR UPCOMING
HEARINGS THAT ARE SCHEDULED TO
TAKE PLACE IN JUNE?
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT AND
SEE HOW THESE REPUBLICAN MEMBERS
REACT TO THIS VERY ADEPRESSIVE
AND EXTRAORDINARY MOVE BY THE
JANUARY 6TH SELECT COMMITTEE TO
ISSUE SUBPOENAS TO SITTING
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
>> AND THAT IS A HUGE MOVE.
RYAN, PLEASE STAND BY.
I WANT TO BRING IN OUR SPECIAL
CORRESPONDENT.
JAMIE, ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THIS
MOVE?
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF TALK ABOUT IT.
I THINK THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO THOUGHT THEY WERE NOT
GOING TO DO THIS.
THIS IS AS RYAN JUST SAID, IT IS
A POLITICAL TSUNAMI.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT IS
UNPRECEDENTED TO SUBPOENA FELLOW
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN SOMEONE
MIGHT BE CALLED IN FRONT OF THE
ETHICS COMMITTEE, BUT THIS IS AS
RYAN SAID, A VERY AGGRESSIVE
MOVE.
YOU HAVE TO ASK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS.
PRACTICALLY, WILL IT CHANGE
ANYTHING?
WILL THESE SUBPOENAS MATTER TO
THESE FIVE REPUBLICAN MEMBERS?
OR ARE THEY GOING TO IGNORE IT?
WILL THEY BE ENFORCEABLE?
YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHETHER THE
COMMITTEE IS DOING THIS TO MAKE
A POINT THAT THEY WENT AS FAR AS
THEY COULD, OR DO THEY HAVE SOME
INFORMATION THAT ONE OR MORE OF
THESE FIVE MEMBERS MIGHT BE
WILLING TO TESTIFY?
THAT A MEMBER TO GOING TO SAY I
AM NOT GOING TO DEFY A
CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA, BUT SO
THEY WANT THE COVER OF THE
SUBPOENA WHICH WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT.
BUT THE POLITICAL FALLOUT OF
THIS IS HUGE, BECAUSE IF THE
POLLS ARE CORRECT, AND THE
REPUBLICANS TAKE BACK THE HOUSE
IN THE MIDTERMS IN 2020, THIS
SETS UP THE POTENTIAL OF THE
REPUBLICANS THEN GOING AFTER THE
DEMOCRATS.
WILL THEY WANT TO SUBPOENA NANCY
PELOSI OR SOMEONE ELSE?
SO I THINK THERE WAS A RED LINE
HERE THAT SOME MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DID NOT WANT TO CROSS.
THEY DECIDED THEY'RE GOING TO
CROSS IT.
>> AND I'M HOPING WE CAN PUT
THAT GRAPHIC BACK UP WITH THE
PICTURES OF ALL THE MEMBERS NOW
WHO HAVE BEEN SUBPOENAED HERE SO
WE CAN KIND OF TICK THROUGH WHAT
WE KNOW OF SOME OF THEIR
INVOLVEMENT AND OF COURSE,
McCARTHY IS THERE AT THE TOP.
HE'S THE HOUSE MINORITY LEADER.
WE'VE PREVIOUSLY REPORTED ABOUT
THE PHONE CALL BETWEEN McCARTHY
AND TRUMP THAT HAPPENED WHILE
THE CAPITOL WAS UNDER ATTACK ON
JANUARY 6TH.
HE HAS INSIGHT INTO PERHAPS
TRUMP'S STATE OF MIND DURING THE
CAPITOL ATTACK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
SCOTT PERRY WHO IS NEXT ON THE
LIST THERE, THEY WAS ASKED BACK
IN DECEMBER TO VOLUNTARILY SIT
FOR AN INTERVIEW AND HE REJECTED
THAT.
HE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO TELL
HIS SIDE OF THE STORY TO THE
COMMITTEE PREVIOUSLY, BUT THEY
WANT TO TALK TO HIM ABOUT THE
ATTEMPTED EFFORT TO INSTALL THAT
FORMER DOJ OFFICIAL JEFFREY
CLARK IS ACTING AG, AND IT WAS
THAT JEFFREY CLARK WHO WAS
WILLING AS OUR REPORTING GOES TO
GO ALONG WITH TRUMP'S PLAN, AND
THE TRUMP ALLY PLAN TO TRY TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
ANDY BIGGS THERE FROM ARIZONA.
WE'VE LEARNED HE PARTICIPATED IN
MEETINGS AT THE WHITE HOUSE, HAD
DIRECT CONVERSATIONS WITH TRUMP
LEADING UP TO AND DURING THE
CAPITOL ATTACK, AND THERE WAS A
DECEMBER MEETING INVOLVING ANDY
BIGGS IN WHICH HE AND OTHER
MEMBERS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
DISCUSSED A PLAN TO HAVE PENCE
TAKE ACTION TO TRY TO REFUSE TO
CERTIFY STATE'S ELECTORAL VOTES.
MO BROOKS WAS AT THE RALLY
BEFORE THE CAPITOL ATTACK AND
HAD THE NOW INFAMOUS QUOTE ABOUT
NEEDING TO START TAKING DOWN
NAMES AND KICKING ASS.
HE HOLD THE CROWD TO CARRY THE
MESSAGE TO CAPITOL HILL, AND JIM
JORDAN THERE, WE'VE LEARNED,
EVEN THOUGH HE HAS TRIED TO DENY
AT ONE POINT THAT HE AND TRUMP
SPOKE AT LENGTH ON JANUARY 6TH.
TURNS OUT IT WAS AROUND TEN
MINUTES THEY HAD A PHONE
CONVERSATION THAT DAY.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
WAS DISCUSSED IN THAT PHONE
CALL.
PLEASE STAY WITH ME.
I WANT TO BRING IN OUR LEGAL
ANALYST JENNIFER ROGERS AND JEN,
FIRST YOUR REACTION TO THIS
ACTION TAKEN BY THE COMMITTEE TO
SUBPOENA FELLOW MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
>> WELL, IT'S A BIG DEAL.
THEY TYPICALLY DON'T DO THIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF KIND OF
GENTLEMEN'S AGREEMENTS WITH THE
WAY THAT CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS
TREAT EACH OTHER EVEN WHEN
THINGS GET KIND OF NASTY.
THE FACT THAT THEY'VE GONE AHEAD
AND SUBPOENAED THESE LAWMAKERS
REALLY MEANS THAT THE GLOVES ARE
OFF.
I THINK THAT THE FOLKS IN CHARGE
OF THE COMMITTEE REALIZE THAT NO
MATTER WHAT THEY DO, REPUBLICANS
ARE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO THWART THEIR MISSION OF
BRINGING THE TRUTH TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO
RETALIATE IF THEY TAKE THE
CONGRESS DURING THE NEXT
SESSION.
IT DOESN'T MATTER, AND GIVEN
THAT, I THINK THEY'RE SMART TO
GO AHEAD AND PUT THE SUBPOENA ON
THESE FIVE LAWMAKERS.
I DON'T THINK THAT THEY WILL
VOLUNTARILY COMPLY.
BUT AT LEAST THEY'VE TAKEN THAT
NEXT STEP WHICH IS IMPORTANT.
>> I DO WONDER, RYAN NOBLES, IF
OF THESE FIVE MO BROOKS MIGHT BE
SOMEBODY WHO IS WILLING TO
COOPERATE GIVEN HE AND TRUMP
HAVE HAD A RECENT FALLING OUT.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S
CERTAINLY PART OF WHAT THE
COMMITTEE IS SPECULATING, AND
THERE WAS THIS INTERESTING
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE AFTER THE
FORMER PRESIDENT RESCINDED HIS
ENDORSEMENT OF MO BROOKS AND THE
ALABAMA SENATE RACE WHERE BROOKS
WAS CRITICAL OF WHAT TRUMP HAD
TO SAY, AND WENT EVEN TO
CLAIM -- TRUMP WAS ASKING HIM TO
RESCIND THE ELECTION RESULTS
LONG AFTER THE INAUGURATION OF
JOE BIDEN.
THE COMMITTEE SEEMED TO HAVE
SOME INTEREST IN HIM AT THAT
TIME.
HE ALMOST SEEMED OPEN TO THAT
CONVERSATION.
HE SHUT HA DOWNRIGHT AWAY WHEN
THEY SENT HIM A LETTER ASKING
HIM TO VOLUNTARILY COOPERATE.
BUT WHAT I THINK IS INTERESTING
ABOUT THE TIMING OF ALL THIS IS
WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
COMMITTEE JUST IN THE PAST FEW
WEEKS WHEN WE PRESSED THEM ON
THIS SPECIFIC QUESTION OF HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THIS
INFORMATION FROM THESE MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS THAT YOU'RE IN
SEARCH OF AND WHAT BENNIE
THOMPSON TOLD ME A WEEK AGO WAS
THEY LEARNED SO MUCH ABOUT THIS
INVESTIGATION FROM THE TIME THAT
IT LAUNCHED LAST SUMMER OVER THE
PERIOD OF TIME THEY BROUGHT IN
HUNDREDS OF WITNESSES TO BE
DEPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE.
THAT THEY COLLECTED THE RECORDS
LIKE THESE TEXT MESSAGES FROM
MARK MEADOWS, THE EMAILS FROM
JOHN EASTMAN, THE THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS FROM THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES FROM THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE.
THOMPSON SAID THEY HAVE LEARNED
INFORMATION ABOUT THE ROLE THAT
THESE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS MAY
HAVE PLAYED IN THE DAYS LEADING
UP TO JANUARY 6TH.
AND JANUARY 6TH ITSELF.
AND THE COMMITTEE WANTS TO GIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN
THAT CONDUCT.
SO TO JAMIE'S POINT ABOUT
FILLING IN GAPS HERE AND ASKING
THEM EXACTLY WHAT ROLE DID YOU
PLAY HERE ALMOST TRYING TO OFFER
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE
THEIR SIDE OF THE STORY, THE
COMMITTEE BELIEVES THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
AND SO THAT'S PART OF THE REASON
THAT THEY'RE ISSUING THIS
SUBPOENA, BECAUSE THEY JUST HAVE
BEEN RELUCTANT TO DO SO.
I THINK THE COMMITTEE IS IS
SAYING WE HAVE INFORMATION THAT
IS VALUABLE TO OUR
INVESTIGATION, AND YOU CAN
EITHER BE A PART OF IT OR NOT,
BUT WE'RE GOING TO PRESENT IT
ANYWAY.
>> LET ME READ THE STATEMENT WE
GOT FROM CHAIRMAN BENNIE
THOMPSON.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE HAS LEARNED
SEVERAL OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
INFORMATION RELEVANT TO OUR
INVESTIGATION AND TO THE ATTACK
ON JANUARY 6TH.
AND THE EVENTS LEADING UP TO IT.
BEFORE WE HOLD THE HEARINGS, WE
WISH TO PROVIDE MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS MATTERS
WITH THE COMMITTEE VOLUNTARILY.
REGRETTABLY, THE INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING SUBPOENAS TODAY HAVE
REFUSED, AND WE'RE FORCED TO
TAKE THIS STEP TO HELP ENSURE
THE COMMITTEE UNCOVERS FACTS
CONCERNING JANUARY 6TH th.
WE URGE OUR COLLEAGUES TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW, DO THEIR PATRIOTIC
DUTY AND COOPERATE WITH OUR
INVESTIGATION AS HUNDREDS OF
OTHER WITNESSES HAVE DONE.
RYAN NOBLES, JAMIE, AND
JENNIFER, THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US AS WE TRIED TO
PROCESS THIS DEVELOPING STORY,
THE BREAKING NEWS.
FIVE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, ALL
REPUBLICANS